time is always fading in XCOM - and it's
never on our side as we train our next
Soldier drop them into battle and fight
for humanity survival we can only make
the best of the minutes we have left
will probably fail but we'll move on
anyway
following in the footsteps of 2012's
XCOM enemy unknown this sequel is a
brutal unforgiving strategy game XCOM
two places us in command of the human
resistance as they rise up against the
Advent an alien regime that has governed
earth for twenty years as opposed to the
soldiers of enemy Unknown XCOM two's
rebellion is on the offensive we're no
longer staunch defenders we're a
desperate guerrilla force this change in
the script supports numerous tweaks to
the XCOM formula each for the better
we're still building an army researching
new technologies and putting them to use
in squad based strategy missions but
these missions are less about repelling
the aliens and more about sabotaging
their global operations whenever we can
we loot supply trains intercept
communication signals and destroy
weapons facilities to halt the advents
plan for human eradication
XCOM to ties its narrative and gameplay
together in such a way that every
mission feels critical and every shot
carries weight the mission objectives
have changed but so too have the methods
we use to complete them XCOM 2
implements a new concealment mechanic in
which your soldiers drop into missions
unnoticed allowing you to sneak past
enemies or coordinate acts on
unsuspecting patrols this further
elevates the idea of guerrilla warfare
but it also allows for exhilarating
ambushes as you lob grenades into groups
fire machine-gun rounds as they scatter
and pick off the stragglers before they
have a chance to react initiating
firefights in XCOM to take just as much
consideration as finishing them this
game also uses procedural map generation
to ensure a different mission each time
your squad leaves the dropship this
dynamism
coupled with the aforementioned stealth
mechanics extends XCOM 2's longevity
long past that of enemy Unknown in which
missions grew boring over time in fact
the entirety of XCOM to unfold in
original ways each time you play it's a
multi-layered experience in which nuance
and refinement exists on each level but
they also combine to form an amorphous
ever-changing whole the squad firefights
lay the foundation with an array of
tactical problems to solve
there are terrain considerations from
the elevation of the battlefield to the
sight lines of the map structures then
there are character classes
a world of possibilities to consider
from the sharpshooter's range to
specialists hacking abilities and more
often than not there's a countdown timer
pushing you forward numbering the turns
until your target escapes or the aliens
extract their secret data there's always
something to worry about something to
consider some way things could go
completely wrong as you fight to keep
your squad alive
XCOM 2's overarching strategy layer
imparts the same sense of urgency and a
similar bevy of obstacles as we move the
humans mobile avenger base across the
globe establishing links with other
rebel cells we also fight the aliens
plan to erase humanity indicated by a
crimson timer at the top of a world map
a real sense of tension forces us to
maintain a constant state of motion
whether by freeing a waylaid country
researching new alien weaponry or
rushing production on a crucial new
structure and yet underlying all of this
is a more personal current we grow
attached to individual soldiers as they
perform spectacular feats and rise in
the ranks we rely on our best leaders
and root for rookies to prove themselves
XCOM to maybe a war game but it doesn't
ignore the boots on the ground strategy
plans after all are only as good as the
soldiers putting them into action in the
end X come to is fantastic not just
because of its refined individual layers
but how seamlessly they all interact we
think on different levels during
playthroughs bouncing between the
commander's chair
the scientists lab and the sergeants
eyes if enemy Unknown was a chess game
its sequel is two simultaneous chess
games against players with more pieces
on the board every once in a while
however XCOM 2 is difficulty surpasses
challenge and becomes a little unfair
for the most part enemies abide by the
same restrictions as we do but sometimes
they shoot through walls and dodge
point-blank shotgun bursts when ex-con 2
breaks its own rules
Baltar's but the vast majority of the
time XCOM two's difficulty is more than
fair we will make mistakes but that's
kind of the point
failure is not just a possibility in
XCOM - it's a necessary presence this is
the rare game that's less about choices
and more about the consequences
thereafter we play we learn we strive to
get better the entire process is a
stunning display and how to make failure
meaningful so time keeps ticking the
best we can do is make the right choices
when we have the chance
XCOM - in parts the weight of those
decisions and that's what makes it
extraordinary
it's mathematical emotional and
thoughtful all at once it's exhilarating
even in the face of failure it's
compelling even though we often lose
victory is the goal but it's also an
afterthought here it's the complex
journey that counts
you